Bangladesh inaugurates its first nuclear
power plant in a virtual ceremony
attended by prime minister Sheik Hina
and Russian President Vladimir Putin
Putin praised 50 years of relations
between the two
countries Bangladesh is our tested Ally
and partner our relationship is built on
the basis of mutual respect equality and
benefits but the project comes with many
challenges Bangladesh has been
struggling to cope with inflation power
cuts and Rising energy costs and after
borrowing more than $4 billion from the
international monetary fund the lender
is Raising questions of the country's
foreign currency reserves bad loans and
a high inflation nuclear power is seen
by some as potential way out this more
than 122 billion project comes with
geopolitical toll as well as Financial
challenge but this is a flagship project
with us and European sanctions barring
Russia from much of the international
banking system Bangladesh is reported to
have for the planned using Chinese un
the geopolitical tool here is
essentially the currency uh of payment
to Russian sources so therefore
alternative currency will also become a
major geopolitical game play uh for the
government in due course of time so
therefore the government has to be very
very
careful the First Consignment of uranium
arrived in Dhaka from Russia last
Thursday via special air cargo plane the
following day it was moved to a nuclear
power plant side 200 km west of Dhaka by
Road under heavy
security construction delays high cost
and public fears about nuclear safety
and managing the plants waste are also
growing one of the uh important aspect
of decarbonization is nuclear power
because you know renewable energy
whatever we say is really not that
powerful enough at this moment
especially for developing countries we
do not have enough land so we may have
to depend more on uh sort of uh nuclear
power and sort of renewable import
Russia and the United States rivalry May
POS a test for dhaka's policy of
neutrality but it seems determined that
won't stop it moving forward with
nuclear power tanit Chri Al jazer
dog make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer